okay so let's just start out um carolina
you want to tell me a little bit about
the program
yes of course the nevada promise
scholarship is a
law that was created in 2017 that allows
students in high school to apply for up
to three years of a scholarship
at csn and the application of the
scholarship also allows the student
i'm sorry about that to transfer that
scholarship
not only to csm but also to other
community colleges in the state
but it's very attractive it's an offer
that is very attractive to a lot of our
students
and basically what it covers is tuition
and mandatory fees that are not paid by
any other gift aid
and if you think about it gift date is
basically your fafsa
you know any free money which is the
pell grant
any millennium scholarship funding
private scholarships
so basically the college looks at all
the sources of funding
and if at the end there is a balance of
a tuition or mandatory fees that nevada
promise will kick in and pay for that
awesome so pretty much go to
college for free pretty much almost
almost
the student does have to um pay for
the cost of books that is also pretty
high so that's something that
we encourage them to seek for other
sources of funding like
private scholarships for example um also
internally at csn we have an application
where they can go in
and look for other opportunities you
know always getting
trying to make sure that they get the
best you know financial aid package for
themselves
okay so um you are
here for a special reason today to tell
us
what you need from the valley right now
from people in the valley right now
go ahead and tell them of course so part
of the nevada promise scholarship
requirements
is that our students um are paired with
a mentor
and this mentorship relationship will
last all the way to
their graduation or transfer from the
college on
so at this moment in time we were able
to recruit almost 5 000 students
for the 2021-2022 academic year
so the kids that we're working with
right now are still in high school you
know
trying to finish their high school
degree in the spring semester
so next year around march is where we
need to have about 450
qualified mentors to help us get these
kids
in college and then through college so
the ask is very simple we need your time
you know this is
a giving season um i know a lot of
people are used to just donating funds
but we're asking for something even more
special and that is your time
so we need you to think about um
a way that you can spend five hours
with a student or you know up to ten
since your choice
and during each semester you know right
now that their high school students
and they have to meet until june 1st to
qualify
and then after that every semester for
five hours
at least um just to check in and see how
they're doing
how you know school is progressing if
they're adapting well if they need
anything
so that you know our students feel
connected not only with the
college but also with the community um i
can tell you i have
nine students myself i'm a mentoring my
husband is mentoring
and a lot of my friends are mentoring to
you and it's very rewarding so besides
being my
my job and something that i do as a
passion it has been really really good
for me as a mentor
um i wanted to introduce somebody to you
if that's okay
i brought one of our city scholars uh
adrian bell
today um so that you just you don't want
me
but also from you hey
[Music]
okay so adrian is a prime example of
being a mentee
in the nevada promise scholarship
program and then
you went to challenge from it too right
adrian
yeah yes i'm currently still in college
at the moment okay
still receive funding from the promise
okay awesome tell us about your
experience so
just want to start off over the back so
i was born and raised in detroit but now
i am a las vegas native love it here so
far
but growing up one of the struggles for
me was both my
parents did not go to college which
means that when it did come time for
college
i couldn't really turn for them to help
they they didn't have the experience
about college they didn't know how to
navigate about it so i remember i was in
high school
and i was sweating bullets because i was
afraid i didn't know
who to talk to about college i didn't
know
who to connect with because my my major
in college right now is business
and always heard throughout high school
that you need to have networking you
need to network
with certain people when you're in
business i was scared of networking
because i didn't know when to
where to start who to talk to where to
begin but
through applying through the nevada
promise scholarship
they gave me a mentor my mentor name is
hillary bootrico
and i can say that if it wasn't for her
i wouldn't be speaking to you today
if it wasn't for her i wouldn't have a
college experience like i did if it
wasn't for her i wouldn't have the
resources that she
provided for me one thing when it comes
to
mentoring for me was it offered me that
support system
and when i talk to students and parents
about why it is that the scholarship
itself is unlike any other in the valley
it's because of the mentorship it's it's
one thing to provide
funding to a student to help them earn
their degree
through knowledge but it's another thing
to sup provide them with the support
system
on while they're on that journey i i can
truly say that
thank you miss hillary bootrico for
being my mentor because she has
allowed me into her inner circle she has
provided me with the resources as i
said she has led me into her inner
circle to meet
new people and clients that can help me
along my journey
and that's the thing about the
mentorship a true scholarship to me is
like i said
not only a scholarship that provides you
with the money but provides you with the
support system
because right now i just want you to
think i'm sure
all those at home all those who that
will watch this can think of at least
one person in their life one person who
has made a change in their life
although we may have put in the work we
may have been burning the midnight oils
but i can assure you that we've all had
at least one person that
helped us on that journey and that's
what a mentor is to the scholarship
it's someone that has a mentee i can
tell you that we can lean on
especially in a time like this like like
this as catalina said
mentors all we're asking for you is time
be there for a mentee provide your time
in a time like this
mentees i can speak from experience we
need that more than ever
because college it's in it's an amazing
experience
but if you don't have the mentee or the
necessary support system then
i can assure you that college can be
scary
yes it can especially during a time like
this where
you are not really amongst your peers
because you're
at home right you're you're doing it
distance learning
so um i know it's good to have that
support you know during the time like
this carolina
adrian has been a great example you know
just speaking
so eloquently about what the mentorship
program means to him
so for people who want to you know sign
up and definitely become a mentor
and um be there for kids like
adrian what what what are you looking
for in a mentor what should they know
well we're looking for people from from
all backgrounds honestly and
it doesn't matter what your level of
education is you have something to offer
and what we would like to see is a
person that's well-rounded
that talks about life experience as well
as professional
career experience a person that can
fill out an application that is able to
allow us to do a background check
csn will pay for that and then there is
a small training that they need to do to
learn more about the scholarship the
requirements what's needed
from the students so that when you're
talking to them you know exactly what
they're going through
and um at the end well basically it's
just um a matter of waiting until we
have
all the eligible students ready to go in
march to receive information
about the student and their parent
because again they're minors and we want
to make sure that they're
taken care of and we invite the the
parents to know the mentor
and to also us adrian said so well
invite them to their inner circle
they're part of that family now so while
the student is a minor in
the high school we invited as i said the
parents to be part of it
so they have a conversation with the
student at least one time
during their high school years we asked
for that to happen before
june 1st there is a small forum it's an
online form that we have on our website
they fill it out
we give the student credit and then once
the student is qualified as i said
after that it's every year until the
student graduates at least five
hours every semester and they can come
to our website
and csm.edu for slash promise
and just click on mentorship and all
that information is going to be there
for them
that sounds like a really good program
and um got another
question so as far as the mentorship
star um
goes does it start when they're like a
junior
or a senior in high school like when
does that start and how many
i know it happens as they're in college
right
when does it start we started earlier we
started as the student is
basically completing their college
application so
they apply in august august 1st to
october 31st
so our application window for the
students is really close right now
as i said we have 5 000 students right
now in high school currently seniors in
high school that are trying to get their
high school diploma first
because that's one of the requirements
so as you're going through all these
intense processes you know graduating
from high school applying to college
we need a mentor we need a mentor to be
there and say hey you can do this
i did it we survived it's okay so
basically
one time during you know this
march to june a portion of
the the cycle you know to apply to
college and then once the student is in
college
immediately after so the fall semester
when they start they have a mentor
until the end of their career at csn
awesome this is a great program and it's
definitely something i think i want to
look into
i understand what it's like to you know
have been in college and
you know to definitely need that support
you know it's a great experience
but it's even an even better experience
when you have that support
so do either of you carolina or adrian
do you have anything
else you want to share um sure i can one
more thing
um it's always important to be grateful
and we want to be very grateful to the
community
we have in the past had great support
and the very first year we had over a
thousand four hundred mentors that
applied
so we hope for something similar we hope
that
you know we our story and the story of
our students moves you and
then you understand that it matters your
time matters
and we hope that you know in the middle
of all the things that you can be doing
right now
that you spend a little time with our
kids and they need you
so we're hoping for 450 so companies
if you have a group of employees that
are interested in
doing something like this community
service please
reach out let us know and we will be
here to support you every step of the
way
it's not hard i promise you it's
actually very very rewarding so thank
you so much for your
time i really appreciate it what about
you adrian
you got anything i have one last thing
to say thank you for offering
um i just wanted to say that on even the
mentors side
as my mentor told me small impacts make
big change
so in order to change the community in
order to change the world
it just begins by changing one person's
lives you talk about you want to make a
better future
this is how you do it like i said i keep
coming back to
the time that we're in today we need to
come together as people
as a community as a nation more now than
ever
and being a mentor to a student who can
use the insight a perspective and the
guidance in their own personal future
this is the way to start so please if
you want to be a mentor please contact
the
nevada promise office so you too can
help a mentee
become the best version of themselves
oh thank you so much well said
whoa sad beautiful you're such a special
young man you keep your head up and you
keep going
and you stay strong okay no matter what
because there's a bright future for you
there's a bright future ahead
i will thank you thank you so much and
thank you carolina thank you for taking
this time to do this interview with me
it's our pleasure thank you so much for
having us